how about some props courtesy of points
bet for tonight's game between
the los angeles chargers and the las
vegas raiders what a strange
sound that has when it was just san
diego and oakland not that long ago
more passing yards tonight justin
herbert or
derrick carr the points bet over under
has herbert at 277.5
carr at 270.5 we're big fans of justin
herbert and look derek carr has played
extremely well this year it's so close
i tend to think that the chargers are
going to be more likely to throw it all
over the place although i saw a report
this morning both keenan allen and mike
williams true game time decisions due to
injury that would affect
herbert's ability to do what he would
like to do in the passing game and of
course derek carr doesn't have henry
ruggs the rookie receivers on the covet
19 reserve list
i'm gonna go herbert though just because
i i just
i think that the chargers are gonna be
looser they got nothing to lose let's
go out and throw it around let's try to
be aggressive
and stretch the field and score points
and try to get the raiders on the ropes
and keep them on the ropes and maybe end
their playoff hopes
will justin herbert break the rookie
passing touchdown record by throwing
three touchdowns points bet has him at
plus 150 to go over two and a half
passing touchdowns he's quietly had
a spectacular rookie season at
quarterback
we had been so focused on joe burrow and
then when burrow got injured
and borough was going to break all the
records for rookie
passing except for interceptions then
justin herbert became the presumptive
rookie of the year candidate and if he
sets the rookie passing touchdown record
he's got three games left to do it he
only needs three he will
that gives him a a leg up on being the
the rookie of the year i'll say that
tonight he won't go over two and a half
i would take the under it's plus 150 to
go
over two and a half passing touchdowns
more rushing yards tonight austin eckler
for the charges of josh jacobs
for the raiders points bet has the uh
over under at eckler for 55 and a half
jacobs at 77.
the raiders defense has allowed 200 or
more rushing yards in two straight
games you know jacob's been a little
banged up i i still think that what
we're going to see from the raiders is
an
effort to establish that run especially
without rugs present
the absence of rugs allows the chargers
defense to
be a little more aggressive when it
comes to stopping the run
i i let me say that i believe
uh jacobs will have more rushing yards
but but how about eckler
is more likely to beat his over under a
55 and a half
better bet to get to 100 or more
receiving yards tonight keenan allen
again i mentioned he is a game time
decision he is plus one seven to get to
a hundred
darren waller is plus 275. hey
waller uh it's feaster famine he had
that huge game a couple of weeks ago
against the jets not nearly as huge
against
the colts allen has 975 yards
this year on an nfl high 144 targets
i'll go waller just because i like the
odds a little bit more and because
we know he's going to play we don't know
if keenan allen's going to play and with
henry rugs out waller may get
more balls thrown his way by derek carr
finally will the chargers allow a
special teams touchdown
points bet has yes at plus 1500
the chargers have allowed three special
teams touchdowns this season's two of
them two weeks ago against new england
i'll go ahead and say no you can't count
on a special team touchdown happening
although they tend to occur
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports